All our own builders, whereas our company is kind of targeting larger profile borrowers, etc.
So I think for us, it's more important to kind of hone down on which analytic website we want to use
before we start sending you guys the data, if that makes sense, right?
If we, let's say we sign up something with you guys, whatever it might be,
but we don't actually have a platform to receive data from,
there's no real point in establishing the relationship.
So I think maybe that might be some miscommunication,
because we were using Forkasa for a few weeks,
and then we stopped because we didn't like it, so we canceled our subscription.
So I just wanted to make sure that you guys are not correlated to Forkasa or directly, you know, working with them.
Okay, great. So yeah, so I think it's more a matter of,
we have to find out what data source works for us before we start, you know, a relationship with you guys,
and we can send it over.
But it is really good. It's not, it's good to know, obviously, that you guys have the capability to script the data
and make sure everything's clean and so on.
Okay, okay.
Also, also just to clarify, so aside from the trial,
we would usually have to give you guys the raw data and you guys, I tilted through it and enrich it, correct?
So that's one way, right?
But we also are, we have expertise in data engineering.
So for example, we have some of our clients, they have said, look, we use Black Knight data
and we have created a data engineering pipeline in their environment that takes data and then runs through the rest of the process.
So if you want to, I can quickly show kids like, what does this system we have actually built for them?
So that basically not only connects your like the lead generation part,
it also connects like you guys are surely using CRMs or maybe you guys are using smoke lakes or data bricks, some warehouses.
And apart from that, there must be some other third party like the data sources you guys are using.
And when you guys are doing any of the research, either in terms of prospect or in terms of like any market level like this, like this energy,
you're doing the manual research.
And what happens like when you have a single source of growth, basically a single platform.
So let me quickly share my screen so I can.
And while you do that, Aryan, just I want to clarify the question that was asked.
I think the question was, hey, will you be, will we be, even if let's say we were to go forward and production all of that,
are we expected, are we the client, S3 Capital, expected to send data in some form to you so that you can work with it?
Or there is another arrangement, right?
That was the question.
Correct.
Yes.
Are we going to always, is this primarily just organizing and I guess cleaning the data and sending it back to us?
Or is it or yeah, are we going to, is the relationship sort of us providing the data?
No, it doesn't have to be.
It doesn't have to be.
This made an assumption that you, you know, this particular POC made an assumption that you had poor class of data.
But if that's not the case, like we said, we have a data engineering expertise where we start working with you and your render right from beginning and construct the whole pipeline,
which, which pulls the data on a regular basis and merges it and all that good stuff.
That answer the question.
Okay.
And also, after, after you guys go over, I guess, the process, I would also like to show everyone who hasn't been previous calls about the additional, I guess, prompting in the, the AI aspect that is like an additional, I guess, tier.
Yes.
You say, I just want to show them now.
So, okay.
So why don't we show that, Arion, the, the querying.
Okay.
So this is the architecture.
What I'm talking like this connects either like any type of like the data source you're talking on any type of like, basically the PLR or the Lend intelligence type of the platform.
Or this is your like the CRM either the pipe drive deals cloud or how it's going to end up the CRM.
And on top of it, like if you're using any data warehouses like us, like a story in your like loan documents apart from that, any type of like handwritten structured or structured data.
And on top of it, like, suppose you have connected the system with your outlook or maybe teams and they're like, you have tons of emails or any type of the communication.
So what this AI orchestration layer on top of it, it is connecting and expecting data from these all the data sources.
And there you can get like, basically, if you have a new meeting and you want to do a national language query, I can quickly show like what are the queries you can do it like simple from the concept.
Don't worry.
Let's just do the query like find the Dallas boroughs with three to four transition last five years or like suppose you have a call with the prospect before the call.
You want to understand like what this prospect is doing how many like the property size there and other it is either which market it is what how many properties is holding.
So just write the query like before I call the checkup up or summarize activity like to be with you or the items anything.
So it's all in the natural language.
There is these the queries are not fixed.
It's just like you're chatting with the GPT.
And what these agents on the backend site, they will pull the data from these data sources and then acclimate the information for you and give you like the consolidated like the results with the citations also from where like these agents got the report.
So it's basically like it's not replacing any job.
It's just like saving your time like in like out of your like the whole time you can have like 70 to 80% kind of the manual that manual work can go.
In this sort of time you can better concern but I deal with your like clients you can better like in the form to chase more clients.
So this is the whole like the picture what we are talking and we are actually deployed it or other like the lenders even in the real estate.
Yes.
So so basically this the in the POC I showed was just on the data we cleaned.
This is taking it to a whole new level.
This part with you was explaining right.
I guess Pt. Victor is new.
I guess he joined person.
Maybe you can just give him like how you are doing it.
Right.
If you will have time then like we have developed an LOS also.
So if you guys have time maybe said the can showcase a quick demo.
All right.
The LOS is working.
Right.
Before we I guess dive into that I just want to I guess clarify once more.
So the main I guess value of this aside from let's say like I guess to start for even if we don't use forecast you guys can work around that correct.
You guys could.
Yeah.
And the main the main I guess purpose of this is to do the data research for us also you guys is that is that what it basically is instead of us doing all the manual work on our end.
We don't we don't even have to directly I guess provide the data like you guys could do all that research for us right.
So let me just want to make sure things are very clear.
So when why don't I go through this real quick that will give you a nice I think I should have showed you this first.
But like you said right.
Can you take any data source and the question was yes right.
It could be black night.
It could be at them.
It could be forecast any other data source.
We have the capability to create this data ingestion pipeline which is number two box over here.
Where we do validation cleaning duplication then we can create a data storage layer here.
Number four you will see we will give you analytics and preview where you as a business users tell us what kind of reports dashboards reports that you want to see right and we can we will create those reports for you.
Right.
So we have given some filters here as per with our experience.
Now typically I don't know how things will work in your environment but typically we have seen once we give you this analytics preview that gives you the tool to apply filters and data and shortlist the borrowers that you want to target for your sale.
Okay.
So so far so good.
So this is the part number five part is the client team doing because you know your business and you know what based on the data that has been provided and filters and views that have been given the tools that have been given to you.
You are able to shortlist what you want to target.
So far so good.
Yes.
And now our entity intelligence system comes into picture where you know how I was telling you we go through so many websites our manual researchers who are experts in doing this open corporate busy pd.
corporation, all kinds of things.
Then sometimes the client will say, hey,
we have bought licenses to Apollo.io,
that's use that as well in your research,
because that all makes the research faster.
So we will use that if you have any paid tools.
Next comes the, right, so this is the paid tools,
these are the public directories.
From this we will say, okay, so here's the email
and here's the phone number,
based on all the research we have done on this.
Sometimes we will even say, hey, skip tracing, right?
Because in the construction and real estate world,
that is a lot, so we find out who the parent entity is
while we do this research.
But anyways, we find the primary person
of whose phone number and email you should be interested in.
We verify it, right, using tools,
zero bounds, for example, for email verification.
And we have this verified output, right,
with all this information, the borrower,
and loan type and property type,
but email and phone number, all of that.
And this is what goes back to you.
Now you have this data, this fully cleaned,
enriched data.
On top of that, what Arian was showing,
we can build on top of that,
a layer, an agentic AI layer,
that now you can use to, you know,
use your simple language query, what not,
to a natural language query to gather insights that will,
so we can build those tools for you.
It's just like, in the simple words,
it's just like an assistant to you,
like you don't need to dig down in that data,
in this data, what we have brought in,
you can simply write the query,
like now give me like top 10 leads in the Dallas,
top 10 borrowers in the Dallas.
So what agents will do,
they will dig down in that data,
they will do like all the filtering,
they will do it by the user,
they will simply give the table,
with the top 10, like the borrowers of the landed data,
whatever you want to look at.
And so,
I'm sorry, so just to, I guess, better understand,
so, classrooms capabilities, basically,
can we just provide like a certain criteria,
like let's say like market or like asset type,
and then you guys generate the borrowers
from your own data sources,
like those data sources from step one of this like diagram,
or do we have to provide a list of properties of borrowers?
So you guys, so we just give the criteria,
the search criteria, and you guys do the rest?
No, the first one, right, the data source,
that will be your data source.
So we are not in the business of creating data,
like, you know, like Black Knight at Forkassa, right?
Those companies specialize, right,
in getting that county level transaction data
and do all kinds of engineering on it and sell it, right?
Which is what the client buys.
So we are not in the business of that.
We work with clients who are buying
one of the several data sources.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, yeah, I understand that, okay, thank you.
Right, so because that's not our expertise,
you know, companies like Black Knight,
I mean, I think they are around since the 70s, right?
That expertise and duplicating that expertise
just doesn't make sense.
But we do know that no matter what that data is,
there are problems with this data, all clients, right?
I have heard things like 50% of the email
and phone is incomplete, inaccurate.
They don't have skip level tracing.
So there are problems with that data as well,
and that's where we come into picture.
I see, just to basically you guys clean the data.
That's what works the best, organizing and cleaning.
Cleaning and enriching.
Enriching.
Enriching, enriching it, because like you could be,
they could give, just to give examples,
they could give a Gmail as I guess the contact info
or something like that.
Right.
What you guys do is you guys point that out
and you guys clarify it and give it actually.
Yes, we have a way of cross checking,
digging in this and that,
and then the next thing you know,
you have the company email address of that person.
And there's one more thing what we are doing,
like with not much clients.
So a couple of the client, they asked us,
like, can you cross check these leads also?
So like, are the manuals just in there doing the phone calls?
And out of like 10 leads,
suppose do like the two prospects pick the phone.
So those are kind of the thing,
like we are the actual prospects
and you have the hot leads.
Yeah, so we provide, yeah, good reminder, Aryan.
So we also have added a layer of saying,
hey, we can make those cold phone calls on your behalf.
Right.
And what our team tells us,
the teams who are working on it,
out of the 10 borrowers they reach out to,
typically, typically two of them will say,
hey, I'm interested to go to the next step
at which it is handed off to the business,
to the client that look, this is your hot lead.
Okay, that makes more sense.
Okay, perfect.
Thank you.
That makes sense.
Okay.
And then also know that you can pick and choose also,
like we are happy to give this end to end.
We have done this, we are experts in it,
but you say, you know what, I don't have this yet,
but I'd like to take the manual research,
one or two people and start with that.
Or whatever combination, it doesn't have to be everything.
Hi.
Perfect, sorry.
No, yeah, sorry, sorry.
Nobody's, so just a quick question,
like what LOS or which LOS you are using?
Okay.
The question was the LOS, the loan origination system.
Just changing the topic a little bit here.
You guys.
Yes.
So I think one thing too,